The vision of kids is rapidly growing when
they are young. And once they reach 6,
it's completely developed. However, one
in five children have a vision disorder.
Because children don’t know better, to them their
vision seems normal. Where one kid sees an eight,
the other might see a three. Too often,
teachers and adults also don’t know the
signs of a child’s impaired sight and wrongly
label them as slow or learning disabled.
That’s why all kids should have a professional
eye check every one to two years. If that cannot
be provided, it’s important for parents and
teachers to learn how to detect the condition.
Here are some signs to spot eye problems.
A student asks to change seats from back
to front. They look into their peers’ notebook
instead of the board. They squint their eyes
to focus on objects in the distance. They
look at things really close up. They execute
handiwork poorly and their handwriting
is extraordinarily bad. Sometimes kids
even walk clumsily. Or show some more explicit
symptoms like tearing or itching of the eyes.
To perform a simple eye test, have your
student close one eye and read out loud
a standard Tumbling E Chart from six meters away.
School children age 6 or above should be able to
read all lines including the one labeled
2030. Then repeat it with the other eye.
When they do the test, observe the students’
posture and behavior. They shouldn’t have
to move or tilt their head, turn their eyes
or constantly blink just to read the chart.
If you identify a child with an eye problem,
please inform the parents. And if available,
the school’s doctor or principal. It’s
important to care early and to help kids
learn and live better, and to prevent
further eye diseases. After the kid has
received proper care by an eye specialist,
you might see a massive study improvement.
See below the link to download a
basic Tumbling E Chart which can
be printed with an ordinary A4 black and
white printer. As always we are looking
forward to receiving your feedback in
the comment section below. Please also
subscribe to our Youtube channel and like
us on Facebook. Thank you for watching!